sometimes the answer to why we enjoyed a
particular movie is very easy to explain
we liked the acting or the writing but
sometimes what we really enjoyed was the
look now it's the job of the
cinematographer to help give each film
its own unique look the use of light
shadows and lenses to help create and
help performances shine here are the
nominees for achievement in
cinematography Birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance Emmanuel Lubezki
the grand Budapest hotel Robert yoman
EDA Lukasz Sol and Rashard l'm Chesky mr
Turner
dick Punk unbroken Roger Deakins and the
Oscar goes to Cheever Emanuel move a
second
this is the second consecutive Oscar win
for Emmanuel Lubezki he won last year in
this category for gravity
Wow this is extraordinary thank you so
much I want to thank the Academy for
this fantastic honor and I would like to
share it with the cast and crew of the
movie and all the nominees I want to
especially share these with my friend
Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu an
extraordinary director to your career
Phoebe your passion and your friendship
I want to share this also with my wife
Lauren and with Ali and Danny with my
parents and my family and thank you so
much